Prince Harry is suing the mirror group
newspapers over accusations of phone
hacking here's what we know
[Music]
for all those keeping count this is
Prince Harry versus the papers round
three joining him to Coronation Street
Stars Michael Lavell and Nikki Sanderson
and Fiona Whiteman the ex-wife of
comedian Paul Whitehouse a group that
have very little in common by the fact
they all claim to have been subjected to
the most obtrusive methods of personal
information gathering they've been
selected as test cases selected to go to
trial from The Wider group of claimants
[Music]
in court documents released at the start
of the trial mgn denied voicemail
interception and any involvement in the
case of Coronation Street actor Michael
Lavelle Bart admitted there was some
evidence of the instruction of third
parties to engage in other types of uig
unlawful information gathering including
with Prince Harry
foreign
has said it unreservedly apologizes for
all such instances of unlawful
information gathering admitting that
this unlawful activity including in
particular knowing where the Duke of
Sussex was going to be at a given time
and the widespread dissemination amongst
mgn journalists of private information
relating to him posed a very real and
large-scale security risk for the Duke
of Sussex his family and his associates
[Music]
mgn is now a very different company but
in this case the claimants team alleged
that over the course of 20 years at the
mirror Sunday Mirror and Sunday people
unlawful information gathering was
happening on an industrial scale
authorized by senior editors including
Piers Morgan who has always denied any
knowledge of phone hacking
[Music]
Prince Harry's hatred of the British
tabloid press is well documented he
cited media intrusion as part of the
reason he and his wife moved to America
while he's been in court before for the
early stages of other claims he's making
this is different it'll be the first
time since the 19th century that a
senior Royal has been called to the
witness box